blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman all right welcome everybody let's
get started after a long um holiday
weekend in the united states federal
holiday we were off with the latest
covet news it's it's really pretty good
uh in five states the covet situation is
getting worse
in 45 plus dc
it's getting significantly better to the
point where cases in the united states
have now plummeted by about 50
since their delta peak so
all good news uh vaccine doses are up a
little bit
um cases are down deaths are now down
and the question is becoming
what happens in the winter season so
let's start at the very beginning how
are cases looking globally globally
cases are down
from their delta peak of about 660 000 a
day an insane number
down to about 400 000 a day 404 000 a
day that's a decline of nearly 39
now in the united states cases are down
even more precipitously if you believe
the data which i think we've talked
about this before
big picture we mostly can even if we're
not getting
the full story from every single state
uh cases in the u.s down from their
delta peak of about 167
000 to about 85 000 cases a day still a
ton of cases
but it's a decline of it's about 50 49
point something percent now the caveat
here
is
do those numbers include what is
obviously slower reporting thanks to the
long holiday weekend these numbers might
end up being adjusted up a little bit as
the testing and reporting kind of
catches up and is integrated into these
numbers but big picture a significant
decline at this point
in terms of deaths which often follow
cases by three to four weeks
globally deaths are down about 34
from their delta peak which remember
it's not the full pandemic peak okay
the delta global death peak was about 10
000 deaths a day at one point we were at
14 000 in a previous peak so down from
about 10 000 a day to like 67.50 within
the united states the death decline is
not
quite as sharp
uh deaths in the u.s down about 26
percent from their delta peak now
around 1400 per day remember this
relevant data point
when we want to think about just how are
we doing
in general
in a normal flu season in the u.s
there's about a hundred deaths a day
again
they're not really a hundred a day
they're concentrated during flu season
you've got more than a hundred a day
during flu season fewer than 100 a day
in the summer but about 100 a day
covet of course is still way way higher
than that multiples higher in terms of
vaccination we are seeing daily vaccine
doses trickle up a little bit remember
that daily vaccinations at one point had
surpassed three million new doses per
day in the u.s that was in mid april
that has come all the way down at one
point down to 500 000 new doses a day
pathetic number completely pathetic and
then as the delta variant started to
surge so did vaccination as joe biden
announced some vaccine requirements
there was another surge in vaccination
and recently we've seen daily doses
administered in the u.s
up to about a million a day we could be
doing so much better we have so many
doses available
but you still prefer to see
one million per day
rather than 500 000.
globally new doses are also up you might
remember last week i said hey guys we're
seeing 23 million doses a day
we're up to 25 million doses a day
globally
these are still really small numbers
but i'll mention them last week we were
seeing
0.29 percent of the population getting a
dose
that's up to now
0.32 percent of the global population is
getting a dose each day these are tiny
tiny numbers but it's an increase and
we'll take any increase that we can get
now compared to the vaccination rate of
any other planet in our solar system
we're doing really well we're really
kicking some ass if we compare earth to
other planets um where do we go from
here not really clear uh we've not yet
won i saw a funny article which said
fauci says we shouldn't declare victory
prematurely and i was thinking
we shouldn't declare victory prematurely
again because we already did i mean some
places never conceded there was even a
battle but there were some premature
declarations of victory as well beyond
beyond that we've got to see what
happens in terms of the winter there is
the view that coinciding with flu season
we're going to see another coke another
coveted peak
if we're going to see that we would
expect to see the numbers turn around
relatively quickly as we're starting to
get into the cold season in much of the
uh much of the country
in terms of those who say we're not
going to see it they are saying no no
because of vaccination and because of
everything that's going on this is now
completely sort of like unlinked from
the seasonality of flu season we're not
going to see a winter spike remains to
be seen in about six weeks we're going
to know but in the interim let's hope
things continue going in the right
direction
we have news in terms of the debt
ceiling i'm going to give you the news
but i'm also going to tell you why i
really haven't been covering
the debt ceiling story
that much and i know that there's some
in the audience who agree with my
reasoning and there's some in the
audience who uh who don't so to begin
with the house is going to vote to
extend the debt ceiling through early
december cnn reporting on this the house
of representatives expected to vote
today to extend the debt limit through
early december after the senate approved
a stop gap measure last week in a bid to
avert a catastrophic default and
economic disaster
once the democratic-controlled house
passes the short-term extension it will
be cleared for president joe biden's
signature
uh janet yellen the treasury secretary
warned lawmakers the federal government
will likely run out of cash by october
18 unless congress raises the debt
ceiling setting up a ticking clock and
high stakes
congress may not even have that long to
act since the deadline is more of a best
guess estimate than a set in stone
deadline that dynamic intensified
pressure on democrats and republicans to
reach a deal to address the debt limit
okay so
what we're talking about here
is
passing a debt limit increase to enable
the treasury to keep borrowing money to
pay bills for two months this would be
temporary
this will set up another round of the
exact same thing in december so why
haven't i been talking about this that
much
quite frankly and and i i want to be
careful with my language
you as an individual
should barely care about this the debt
ceiling was created in the first place
to put a limit on how much debt the
government could take on without
requiring a really clumsy process that
was in place beforehand we don't even
need to go over the process that was in
place beforehand the point was just let
them take on debt but cap it so they
can't go beyond a certain amount without
coming back to us it's sort of actually
uh sahil bloom has a good twitter thread
on this and sahil tweeted this is sort
of like it used to be that you had to
get approval every time you wanted to
buy something on your credit card now
it's you just have a spending limit in
total on the credit card and you can buy
whatever you want until you hit that
limit if you hit the limit you gotta ask
for an increase every once in a while
you're gonna need to raise it why well
the country keeps growing the economy
keeps growing and so even if you
maintain the same percentage of the
economy in debt
the raw numbers are going to go up over
time
but this entire process was basically a
rubber stamp we've got to raise it we've
got to raise it we're a growing country
our economy grows we've got to raise the
debt ceiling
debt ceiling increases remember are
needed
for prior spending
that's already been authorized
republicans like to play this game where
they say we're not going to do this and
allow democrats to keep spending us into
debt oblivion hold on that's
grandstanding that's a lie
it they want to pretend that this is to
stop democrats from spending it's for
prior spending that was already approved
by congress the fear is
if they don't do this the u.s will
default on its debt so then all the
fear-mongering and the headlines start
and republicans say we're going to
default because we have too much debt
and democrats won't stop spending the
reality is we default if republicans
don't raise the debt ceiling which is
supposed to be merely perfunctory some
republicans will say that's the problem
it can't be perfunctory that we go into
more and more and more debt but the time
to talk about that is when you authorize
the spending that now simply needs to be
paid for and what we end up doing is
giving oxygen to something
where nobody really benefits from there
being more stories about the debt
ceiling we're actually giving them
attention
which makes them more eager not to just
raise the debt ceiling and let's
continue so they're gonna get this
solved for two months
it'll come up again in december
it'll get solved again and it's in no
one's interest to actually not raise the
debt ceiling over the long term and if
people didn't ignorantly react to it it
would get less oxygen oxygen to begin
with and it would deflate this as
something that republicans want to get
attention for think about the number of
interviews
over the last you know weeks months
however long
all about this
and in the interviews they're not even
mentioning the fundamental point which
is
we are now republicans we are now
trying not to raise the debt ceiling to
pay for spending we already approved we
already approved the spending it's not
for new spending it's not for joe
biden's new proposals it's just not what
it's for so the reason i haven't been
covering it is this really shouldn't be
a thing
in that this is just a perfunctory part
of running government you want to run
government a different way where this
doesn't come up we could talk about that
you want to have a bigger conversation
about debt and deficit we can do that
but this is for already approved
spending you can't now say well we
approved it but we're not going to cut
the check so to speak or allow the
spending to happen to cover
allow the the debt ceiling to increase
to cover the spending
that's why i haven't been covering it i
don't think any of us really benefit
from talking endlessly about this if you
disagree with me
let me know
next tuesday one week from today
6 p.m eastern we'll be having the david
pakman show live town hall
it will be streaming on one place only
the david pakman show second youtube
channel that's pacmanlive
youtube.compacmanlive
we'll be opening the phone lines members
will get priority but it'll be open to
everyone you can sign up at
joinpackman.com
subscribe free to the youtube channel
youtube.com pacmanlive and we'll be live
next tuesday at 6pm eastern time i hope
to see you there
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcasts too
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
remember that the david pakman show is
primarily funded by viewers and
listeners like you through our
membership program you can grab a
membership at
joinpacman.com whether you watch on
youtube or listen to the podcast by the
way
audio podcast record week last week for
the year more people listened to the
audio podcast last week
than in any week dating all the way back
to the week after the election november
of 2020 when things were crazy i've we
haven't even been promoting the audio
podcast but it is it's going nuts so
thanks to everybody who's been listening
and you can sign up at joinpackman.com
you get a bunch of great perks including
the daily bonus show just for our
members
so um i've talked before about the
problem of chiropractors
and
now we are actually seeing chiropractors
who many of whom are are anti-vaccine
and i'll talk about what i mean when i
say many
chiropractors are increasingly a force
of misinformation as reported by the
associated press i'll let's read a
little bit of this article and then i'm
going to give you some some of my
thoughts
um
this is an article from providence rhode
island about a um event called vaxcon 21
promoted as teaching people the
uncensored truth about covid vaccines
and people went uh participants traveled
from around the country to a wisconsin
dells resort
for a sold out convention that was a sea
of misinformation and conspiracy
theories the featured speaker was the
anti-vaxx activist from the 2020 movie
plandemic the convention was organized
by members of a profession that has
become a major purveyor of vaccine
misinformation during the pandemic
chiropractors
at a time when the surgeon general says
misinformation has become an urgent
threat to public health
an investigation by the ap found a vocal
and influential group of chiropractors
capitalizing on the pandemic by sowing
fear and mistrust of vaccines they've
touted supplements as alternatives to
vaccines
written doctor's notes to allow patients
to get out of mask and immunization
mandates
donated large sums of money to
anti-vaccine organizations and sold
anti-vaccine ads
on facebook and instagram the ap
discovered
one uh chiropractor gave thousands to a
super pac hosting anti-vaccine
pro-trump rally on january sixth they
have also been the leading force behind
anti-vax events like the one in
wisconsin where hundreds of
chiropractors from around the country
shelled out 299 dollars to attend the ap
found chiropractors were allowed to earn
continuing ed credits to maintain their
licenses in at least 10 states going on
to say public health advocates are
alarmed by the number of chiropractors
hitching themselves to the anti-vaccine
movement using their public prominence
and sheen of medical expertise to
undermine the nation's response to a
pandemic that has killed seven hundred
thousand so let's talk about
chiropractors okay
i'm not 100 against chiropractors
i'm about
85
against them and here's what what i'll
tell you by that
um
when you in some places people go to a
chiropractor almost like a primary care
doctor in fact in california
chiropractors can be pcps
and they are often anti-vaccine
and they often promote a ton of
different woo
so the stuff from chiropractors that's a
disaster includes
uh things like for the anti-vaccine
stuff
as well as chiropractic adjustments as
treatments for
uh systemic conditions of different
kinds infections etc uh neck adjustments
back adjustments etc just simply no
evidence that they treat
infections and other systemic conditions
okay number two
a lot of chiropractors are in the woo
stuff like and you can see some of these
on youtube i mean there's people that go
to chiropractors on youtube they film it
and you hear stuff like
make sure to drink a lot of extra water
after the adjust adjustment to flush out
the toxins
released by the back cracking and the
neck stuff that i did that's total
nonsense i mean just when you think
about how the body works
drink water
to flush through the kidneys
for a adjustment it just doesn't make
sense okay so that you've got to be very
very careful with
next stuff check out on youtube and uh
articles
from spine surgeons and back surgeons
about
the risk of neck adjustments and what
can happen from neck manipulations done
by chiropractic so all of this stuff is
horrible huge you know at best you're
spending money on something that will do
nothing
um and at worst you you could end up
really hurt now what's the part that
maybe is okay
there are some things chiropractors do
that are also done by physical
therapists and are more within the realm
of reality as long as you understand
their goal so like for example i once
went to a physical therapist when i was
having some back pain
and they do
some
very specific
back cracking things not where you put a
strap under your neck and pull to extend
no but just some specific back cracking
things which they say this is not really
treatment but while we're building a
routine for you to strengthen muscles
and maybe deal with a spasm or whatever
some of these specific back crackings
can provide some short-term relief okay
beyond that we've got to be really
careful with chiropractors so it's not a
surprise that this is a group
that is doing things that are horrible
including as we covered in florida
saying just come on down and i'll sign
off on a mask or vaccine exemption for
you
um and that is uh extraordinarily
concerning and i'm really glad
that the ap is writing about this
um
it says the purveyors of vaccine
misinformation represent a small vocal
minority of the nation's 70 000
chiropractors many of whom advocate for
vaccines so i think that that's
important and what what i've said to
people when they say so should no one go
to a chiropractor i you could this is
not my idea you can find this
information online what should be done
if you're considering going to a
chiropractor is you call up and you
actually ask their view on chiropractic
adjustments and you say do you believe
chiropractic adjustments can be used to
for example treat things like sinus
infections or i mean you know
cancer imagine what's your view on
vaccination etc you can usually pretty
quickly if you ask there's like five or
six questions you can find online to ask
a possible chiropractor
uh you can pretty quickly suss out like
which which side of things they're on
you can also
more than likely
get what you need from a physical
therapist and there you're talking about
a different different type of setting
and
that may be something to consider as
well but chiropractors increasingly a
source
of anti-vaccine disinformation let's
move on to another source of
disinformation
tucker carlson's show on fox news
is a major
catalyst
of disinformation
and his ratings are really good
so
what is he doing now
he's going further down the conspiracy
rabbit hole to the point that you can't
even understand what he's saying this is
a really common characteristic among
charlatans among pseudo-science
purveyors and others at a certain point
the things they say no longer make sense
to anyone even their followers but
that's okay because their followers
assume it must make sense to someone so
i'm going to just go with it if you look
back at jim jones from the people's
temple this is the guy who got
his followers to drink cyanide-laced
kool-aid and kill themselves his
so-called teachings over time would make
less and less sense to his followers
and some of them would be sort of
conflicted
but the fact that it made no sense
became a source of his power he must
really be telling us some high level
stuff here i had the good sense to start
following him i'm not understanding what
he's saying but it must really be
important stuff
alex jones his conspiracy theories
became and have become increasingly
unintelligible so anyway here's
basically an alex jones type conspiracy
theory
from tucker carlson related to the white
house looking set
that the biden administration used for
joe biden's third vaccine dose look at
all of the things that
tucker carlson infers from the fact that
the white house has like a set that
looks like one room from the white house
take a look at this and keep them
informed of international incidents
instead
they are in some cases freelancing to
crush anyone who opposes their power
mike flynn for example he was briefly
the national security adviser in the
trump administration what we learned
from the destruction of mike flynn
really
was that sure you can elect donald trump
president but does he really run the
executive branch of government sorry and
i'm realizing i started this too late
we're getting to mike flynn in a moment
but let's let's pick it up at the
beginning take a look at the latest
example these are pictures of a fake
white house set that the buy
administration has for some reason
constructed across the street from the
actual white house it's in an auditorium
at the eisenhower executive office
building why go to the trouble they
already have a white house
well stephen miller spent the last four
years in the white house as an adviser
to trump and here's his explanation for
it because he would know quote the
reason biden uses this bizarre virtual
set for televised meetings is not an
actual room like the east room the
cabinet the oval the roosevelt sit room
et cetera a lot of rooms the reason he
does this is because it allows him to
read a script directly from a face on
monitor and without teleprompter glass
that can be seen on camera so this this
is actually quite silly because if that
was the concern you could just do that
by setting up a different camera angle
in any of the rooms tucker mentioned
like even at its at its core it doesn't
even pass the sniff test
oh
now we can't verify that that's true but
it certainly sounds right well maybe joe
biden can't speak from the oval office
because he's not sure what to say so he
has to read it all here
so that raises a much deeper question
the question is not is joe biden
mentally impaired obviously he is and
again we're not going to gloat over it
but a much more important question for
the rest of us is if he's not running
the government
then who is
that's a real question
clearly the fbi the doj and the military
already acting independently of the
elected president of the united states
as you just saw they don't even keep
them informed of international incidents
instead
they are in some cases freelancing to
crush anyone who opposes their power
okay so
it's starting to get very very
conspiratorial and then just to show you
like how far this all goes here's one
one more example
here's tucker's preview of an interview
with trump's former national security
adviser michael flynn
and he's talking about deep state
conspiracy theories
took out with a long interview with mike
flynn it's coming out monday and he told
us what is really obvious to everyone
who watches
an unelected group within washington
effectively runs the country without
reference to voters here's his
assessment
we have two separate governments we have
the one that actually gets elected and
goes into office
and then you have a government inside of
washington dc that operates under no
rules uh no authorities other than their
own or who's ever in charge of them
sounds like that government was still
controlled by barack obama yeah and and
i would say that that's that uh to a
degree is is what we're operating with
today
by the way mike flynn is not some
internet celebrity or conservative
activist he was a three-star general
who became a complete and total lunatic
once he started working for trump or
before and we just didn't notice an
intelligence agency he was the number
two guy for all american intelligence he
spent his entire life working in the
federal government and succeeding at
that so he knows what he's talking about
he is a reliable guide to how the
government actually works
our whole conversation with mike flynn
by the way
he could not be a less reliable guide as
to how the government works mike flynn
seems to have had
something happen that has made him
completely delusional about even the
basic facts of how the world works so
this is a really they're basically
talking about like an obama run deep
state of some kind and this has many
many iterations this is a family of
conspiracies much studied significant
amount of literature on it
sometimes it's called deep state it's a
shadow government of some kind
sometimes you call it the deep state
sometimes it's the freemasons sometimes
it's the jews sometimes it's the vatican
it could be the trilateral commission
the illuminati the bilderbergs
it's it's there's a bunch of versions of
it and this seems to be what tucker
carlson's audience now wants so when we
talk about oan and newsmax
are well beyond fox news in terms of
what they're willing to put on air yeah
it's true in a way
and yet look at what's happening on
tucker's show lately and then in
addition when we say well you've got
msnbc which is left and fox news which
is right sure they're both corporate
media networks with different editorial
bents
but there is nothing on msnbc that is
equivalent to this
uh so this seems to be what tucker's
audience wants and fox news seems to be
gleefully promoting it and and and
signal boosting it and accepting it and
again i think it's because of the
financial incentives even though there
have been advertiser troubles with
tucker
uh and his show
the ratings are still there
and overall this is a good show for fox
news's business model we're gonna have
more of this on our instagram which you
can find at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
all right these next two stories are
going to contain video clips uh really
not suitable for children there's no
gore or anything like that but you'll
understand i think as we go
uh so donald trump held a rally over the
weekend just another rally right who
cares well this one was actually one of
the most disturbing and alarming rallies
i can remember maybe the most alarming
i've seen from trump because it had all
the normal things it had the lies and
we'll look at some of the lies it had
the delusional crowds whose ignorance
has been completely weaponized which we
will look at the cheering at horrible
things all of that
but this rally in the important election
state of iowa
had some notable and key differences
first as dino bedala wrote for cnn
key iowa republican elected officials
were there
at the georgia rally a couple weeks ago
trump attacked that state's republican
leaders this time this weekend in iowa
despite the insanity of trump for the
last six years trump losing the white
house for republicans in 2018 losing the
senate and the white house in 2020
inciting a riot on january 6th iowa's
republican leaders were all there and
they are still supporting him which is a
very dark signal for democracy chuck
grassley as dino bedala wrote after
criticizing trump's incitement of the
january six riots was right there in
iowa this weekend praising donald trump
so after all of it
in now october of 2021 trump is still in
control of the party the blind loyalty
is still there and trump spent the rally
telling horrible corrosive demonstrable
lies about the election of 2020. so
let's jump right in trump heavily into
the xenophobia here he is saying the
afghan refugees or people we'll quote
soon be hearing about he seems to be
alluding to soon they're going to carry
out attacks against the us and you'll be
hearing about it it was oh it was great
they had no idea who was getting on
those planes we still don't have any
idea only three percent were qualified
to be taken
to a place called the united states of
america isn't that something three
percent you're going to be hearing from
those people over the coming years in a
very bad way right trump then talking
about his travel ban as something to
prevent people from coming here who want
to blow up our cities
the democrat bill will also
admit every foreign national
previously denied
under my national security travel ban
remember i had the travel ban everyone
said oh what a horrible thing i said no
we really don't want people in our
country who are going to blow up our
cities if you don't mind
we don't want
we don't want fifth avenue blown up now
remember that the travel ban was
actually targeted at countries that were
not source countries for people who came
here and attacked the united states
trump then moving on to the topic of
abortion saying a democrat support
killing babies even after birth now
that's murder no one supports that it's
also not legal but take a listen to
trump quickly
the bill abolishes the hyde amendment
forcing taxpayers to fund the far left's
extreme abortion agenda ripping babies
from their mother's womb right up until
the moment of birth
and in fact killing babies even after
birth you saw that
in virginia with the governor of
virginia
after birth so that was a widely
debunked fake news story from the right
um a couple years ago actually it's not
true
the crowd maybe doesn't know maybe
doesn't care who knows but they cheer
uh so then we get into the 2020 lies
here's donald trump teasing the idea
that he could he might come back because
remember he didn't concede hillary
conceded he didn't legit admit they
called it everything in the book it was
fine
when i say it now here's the difference
hillary conceded
i never conceded
that's how you fire up
a low information crowd
then trump saying the corrupt media
and democrats used kovid to put in place
mail-in voting
it's hard to even exactly follow what
he's saying
but it's part of the 2020 big lie that
he continues
these people are so corrupt the media
look i don't need to do this but the
media is corrupt and you know what when
i started i'm so proud of this two
things i proved number one the elections
are totally corrupt in our country they
have been for a long time but never like
they were this last time they used covid
in order to cheat and rig
and the other thing is how dishonest the
media was because they were at 96
approval rating before i came along and
now they're like in what the 20s
and then just yeah just to show you how
much he's in control of this crowd the
crowd actually starts chanting trump one
as trump just tells lies about the 2020
election
but let's hope he does
our country needs it arizona needs it
and with all of those numbers being so
horrible
we did
as i've said before
trump without his followers is really
not much
but with the followers it is something
very serious and scary trump then
continuing to struggle with certain
words minneapolis of course minneapolis
that's just par for the course now
that's not working out too well you see
in minnesota minneapolis there i went to
a conference in minneapolis once it was
weird really really weird trump then
referring to someone as uh
personification
instead of persnickety
he was
with us all the way every time i needed
something you know he's very persnippity
sometimes right he's tough persnickety
of course means fussy persnippity me i
don't know what that one means your
guess is as good as mine trump then
hilariously mentions i i mean apparently
he's serious he'll quickly finish
building the border wall when what are
you talking about we will quickly
complete the border wall and we will end
illegal immigration
once and for all we will have to start
it all over again remember he was going
to do the border wall in one term we all
knew he wasn't and he didn't didn't
happen
does the crowd crowd know that do they
care i have no idea
uh maybe this is that same kind of
magical thinking we talked about where
they see themselves as being in like a
war where individual facts don't matter
just if trump says it you've got to
cheer for it because you're part of the
crowd is that what's going on here
and then ultimately trump
wound down the rally with a completely
unintelligible rant about critical race
theory including in the military
we will ban critical race theory in our
classrooms we will ban
that horrible crazy critical race theory
in our military we will ban it from our
workplaces we will bat it from our
federal state and local governments it
will be banned permanently banned and
will never be allowed to come back again
i don't even know what i can really say
about this other than as i've said
before
i find it sort of quaint when they talk
about banning a theory
what they mean is banning the teaching
of it right like how how do you ban a
theory
but it seems what they mean is they want
a gag order which is of course very
authoritarian and very much a
restriction on what people can talk
about quite frankly so absolutely
delusional event the crowd goers as much
as trump we're going to listen to the
crowd goers in this next segment but the
really dangerous cherry on top is that
at this stage of the game this late in
the game
prominent iowa republicans chuck
grassley
still openly supportive of donald trump
after everything he did
2024 is really looking as rough as you
can imagine and we'll have time to talk
about it once we get beyond the midterms
next let's talk about the rally
attendees
so trump had a rally in iowa over the
weekend
we looked at the things that trump
himself said and it was completely out
of this world bonkers trump still
getting support from iowa republicans
chuck grassley was there so were others
what about the people that go to the
rally because without them trump is just
a guy speaking into a microphone
really really great stuff from ron
phillipkowski
cataloging and covering the rally goers
so let's just go through some of these
and you're going to see
really again what we're up against here
is jane jane
says she
decided to move
from alaska to iowa
when she heard trump would be there
this is crazy take a listen
i found out about the rally before i
moved so that was part of the incentive
for moving as well it's my first rally
president trump made someone move to
iowa to go to one of his rallies by the
way this young lady wearing a socialism
sucks hat
there's no socialism in the united
states but
socialism sucks as her hat right what
excites you the most about president
trump oh my gosh everything he tells
everything straight as it is no lies no
bs nothing and that's what this country
needs absolutely no political
correctness and all of that no
how do you how i mean
how
how
this this is the most dishonest
president we've ever seen and part of
what appeals to her is trump tells it
like it is and he doesn't lie she also
moved because trump did a rally i
considered moving actually to louisiana
once when billy joel played i heard
billy joel was playing a concert there i
was like i should really move there that
makes sense okay here's another woman
who explains that her family
hates trump and she breaks down crying
this is really something to see
i know my whole family has turned
liberal and i don't know what happened
because i didn't raise him that way and
they've all been brainwashed to think
that he's the most horrible man ever
when he's saving everyone right i mean
i'm going to start getting emotional
because
everything depends on this america
depends on this we have got to
save we've got to do everything we can
and i'm not even an american citizen i
was born in england but i've been here
so much
that i don't know why i find that extra
funny after the crying i'm not even an
american citizen but she lives here okay
five and this is my home
and we've got to save it we just got to
go but that means that she doesn't even
vote which is interesting that's in the
the
god wins in the end right that's why the
enemy is lashing out right now we know
we know we're going to suffer for a
while but it's going to be good it's
going to be more glorious than anything
we've ever seen and you understand i
mean the guy introduces the full
religious thing
but then she she talks about this idea
of we're going to suffer in the short
run it's all uh
this kind of christian dominionism
extreme ideology have to have faith in
god and pray and do everything we can
everything yeah absolutely we will we
will i mean just keep the faith i do i
have complete faith that this man is
going to save us he's going to basically
saving the world not just us everyone
everyone and i just can't wait until i'm
never gonna say i told you so but i'm
just gonna be just so happy and
i don't know what else to say my husband
was a united states marine and he died
from agent orange from his time in
vietnam and i'm alone
so um i mean that's
you know at least her family figured out
that they shouldn't support trump that's
that's good it shows us that even within
families some people can ultimately see
reason that's good um here's another
woman who explains that during obama
christians were persecuted
but then trump came in and then they had
freedom of religion and trump is like
the most christian president ever which
is just so not factually accurate why is
it that you support president trump so
much oh it's it's it's just it's just
heartbreaking what's going on in our
country right now when president trump
okay when we when we were in obama you
know like as christians we've been
persecuted a lot you know that's not
true
and then when president trump came then
all our rights are back you know there
were no rights that were re-established
for christians under trump
freedom
of religion you always had it it's in
the constitution
you know we
we're free you know president trump is
the most christian pro-christian most
pro-israel trump may actually be an
atheist
it's actually shocking how non-religious
trump has bamboozled so many people into
thinking he's a christian pro-life you
know and all that pro-life he claims at
68 he he became pro-life all his
policies are amazing you know like
uh he really thought as to how to become
patriot you know so and to love this
country so yeah so we
we were really
you know glad for him we're grateful for
him and now what's going on with the
communism all the mandates there's no
communism
you know we're like being strangled you
know that our freedom is being stolen
from us so it's really you know and all
now of course this is like a perfect
example if you actually ask her
give an example of a freedom you've lost
in the last um nine months under joe
biden
you would get an interesting
conversation uh if you said give us an
example of communism in the united
states it would get very interesting the
real question is is this just a low iq
individual or is this a brainwashed
individual
or is it both in some way
um here's one last one just to show you
the craziness some guy
said he was there to deliver legal
documents to trump to help trump i don't
know what the documents are supposed to
do let's see
okay rich go in
our it says you are the 46th president
period says our lord dear mr president
donald j trump i have come to this
deliver legal documents to you so that
you can give them to your legal team
period
our king jesus christ has spoken to put
you back in your office at the white
house now it's funny are they legal
documents or are they religious
documents if it's jesus who has spoken
to put trump back in the white house why
is it even a question of legality like
isn't isn't jesus more powerful than
legality
sincerely rich thomas afterwards i had
the legal documents
oh
here
to put president trump back in office
now well he does watch us so that's very
possible mr trump
look me up i have the documents i'm here
at the rally
i'm waiting to deliver king jesus says
it's time to deliver are you hearing me
absolutely there's a real okay so king
jesus there says it is time to deliver i
don't know uh what we make of this what
i do know is it's really hard to um
reorient these people to reality
whether it's hard because of a just
limited cognitive capacity
whether it's hard because of
brainwashing whether it's
you know
i'm not saying it's mental illness but
whether it's some kind of
emotional imbalance
um it's very tough to fix what we just
saw
let me know your thoughts we'll take a
quick break and be back after this
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show all right so former
president donald trump was interviewed
in an in it can't even really be called
an interview it was really sort of a
softball propaganda piece it was it was
soft propaganda uh that trump and fox
news host sean hannity did together the
big headline from this interview was
that donald trump said
the haitian immigrants are bringing aids
into the united states um and some
people wrote to me and they said you
know david
there's a lot of aids in haiti in haiti
uh um and and so we have to we have to
consider that let's let's look at the
clip and then we'll talk about it here
is trump explaining it all to sean
hannity and you know there's one other
thing that nobody talks about so we have
hundreds of thousands of people flowing
in from haiti haiti has a tremendous
aids problem
aids is a step beyond age is a
a real bad problem so hundreds of
thousands of people are coming into our
country and if you look at the stats if
you look at the numbers
if you look at just take a look at
what's happening in haiti
a tremendous problem with aids
many of those people will probably have
aids and they're coming into our country
and we don't do anything about it we let
everybody come in so first of all i was
not able to find any reporting that
hundreds of thousands of haitians are
coming in i just i just was not able to
find evidence of that
uh it is true that there is a higher
rate of aids in haiti than in many other
countries that's absolutely true
uh it's relevance in terms of what's
going on with immigration
uh particularly
when it is not a virulently contagious
disease
like covid
um
although certainly more serious
it's just weird to make that the focus
again unless you just want to portray a
population as dirty unclean
sick and infected which is like a
classic
of authoritarians
towards minority groups that that's
really what it is if you really want to
have a public health
sort of conversation about migration
that can be done
that's not what donald trump is uh is
trying to do here check out this next
segment this is a segment that starts
with hannity asking trump a question but
then he sort of gives the answer and
it's really weird like where where does
the question end and the propaganda
begin you know you you were last time on
this program and i think we need to put
emphasis back on this
that your conversation with the leader
of the taliban before you ever discussed
any deal of withdrawal was number one it
was
based on
your
your stated threat
that you would obliterate them do you
remember exactly what you said because i
have a source that says you were brutal
to them
and that you said you would destroy them
you would destroy their province you
would destroy it and it would be
everybody in the area would be dead did
you say that everybody
so i what i said and i had a very strong
conversation
i said i hate to start the conversation
this way but that's the way it is
and i said we would do serious serious
harm to them if they killed any of our
soldiers or any american citizen so
really hannity kind of handling the
question and answer for the most part
there
um trump then at this point this is just
amazing
trump talks about vaccination and how a
lot of people now don't want the vaccine
i can't tell if trump is this stupid or
if this is deliberate
trump says
when i was president everybody wanted
the vaccine
now that biden's president a lot of
people don't as if that's something that
makes trump look good
well you know i was saying the other day
is very interesting
during my administration everybody
wanted the vaccine there was nobody
saying oh gee i don't want to take it
now they say that and that's because
they don't trust the biden
administration i can think of no other
reason
but they say
we don't want it we aren't going to take
it when i was there everybody wanted it
and we were doing great with them yeah
well you know so let me let me translate
that for you
what he means is
under under me
my followers wanted the vaccine because
they thought i made the vaccine
and left wingers wanted it because they
understand science and realized neither
i nor joe biden had anything to do with
the vaccine
under biden left-wingers still want the
vaccine because they understand science
and realize that neither trump nor biden
had anything to do with making the
vaccine but suddenly trump's followers
no longer want the vaccine because
they're morons that's what it means and
trump's like that means i'm great aren't
i fantastic as a result of that isn't
that an amazing thing
um trump then says that
the he defeated isis and iran i couldn't
find any evidence of isis in iran but
trump says he did it
we defeated 100
of the isis caliphate
in iraq
and iran
all over but in iraq we knocked out the
by the way we did iran indirectly a very
big favor because they're not big fans
of isis either true but syria we knocked
out a hundred percent and we knocked out
the leadership and we so i was not able
to find any evidence that isis was in
iran i he's right that iranians have
been very much opposed to isis for a
long time
but just kind of weird we knocked out
isis in iran and then lastly a
completely unintelligible moment where
trump says something about you never
used to hear the term mandate but that
we're in great shape or something
well you know we never heard the term
mandate but people have to have their
freedoms and we should be in a great
shape between the people who get it they
should not have to if you get
covet or whatever you want to call
plenty of name wuhan virus the china
virus you could call it a we got plenty
of names but
well you know we
were you able to understand that
because i certainly wasn't but folks
everything is smelling
like this guy wants to run again in 2024
and horribly he actually might have a
shot at winning
one of the things i truly love is when a
radical ideologue gets confused and
doesn't even understand their own rancid
and disgusting talking points when i was
interviewed by jesse lee peterson in los
angeles a couple years ago i had trouble
not laughing when he would use terrible
debunk talking points but like he would
get them wrong about socialism and other
things so today i have a clip for you
that's really emblematic of a lot of the
cove disinformation that's floating
around republican congresswoman marjorie
taylor-green has been a big voice
against vaccine requirements against
masks in favor of various unproven
treatments for covet including
ivermectin she appeared on real
america's voice recently and hilariously
hilariously claimed that iver mekhton
won a nobel peace prize now there's two
layers of confusion here i won't explain
them yet let's look at the clip
ivermectin is a very good drug its
safetiness has been proven for decades
it even won a nobel peace prize
and it is absolutely irresponsible for
the biden administration the cdc uh dr
fauci and any of these doctors to be
advising people to to not prescribe it
isn't that just the best so two layers
of confusion here first of all
ivor mechtin didn't win any nobel prize
and it definitely didn't win a nobel
peace prize there are two scientists
william campbell and satoshi amura
won a nobel prize in 2015
for discovering that a modified version
of ivermectin called avermectin could be
used
to treat infections caused
by roundworm parasites
nothing about a nobel peace prize
nor anything about ivermectin to treat
kovid so consider the fallacious
reasoning here but this is the type of
stuff these right wingers love they
latch onto it marjorie taylor green says
or implies we should be giving
ivormectin for covid to people because
ivermectin won a nobel peace prize and
then you look at it ivor mekden didn't
win any prize especially not a peace
prize
two scientists
won a nobel prize
in medicine
for their discovery
that a different compound
based on ivermectin called avermectin
could be used specifically for treating
roundworm and her view is
nobel peace prize
give it to people for covid but it just
gets repeated and repeated you hear it
once ivermectin won a nobel peace prize
or nobel prize and suddenly you hear the
talking point everywhere and it is
everywhere it spreads uncontrollably
without any real investigation the
reason marjorie taylor green got in
trouble here by the way
is that nobel peace prize is like a
little too much so there's been more
fact checking like really a nobel peace
prize that doesn't that doesn't make
sense had she simply said nobel prize
this would almost certainly have
continued to spread without even more
fact checking of it done which
fortunately did take place sadly her
re-election is likely to happen
she's in a very red district back in
february march there were articles
saying oh she's got a tough uphill
battle big primary challenger
as far as i was able to find this
morning no serious republican primary
challenger
to marjorie taylor green
and it is not looking good at all so we
may well be dealing with another two
years of marjorie taylor green and
another two years of exactly this type
of just humiliating humiliating nonsense
i have a voicemail number that you can
call anytime you want
this is an anti-vaccine caller
who's been calling in for a while she
took up a full three minutes today on
the voicemail that's the max it cuts you
off let's listen to a little bit of it
uh it's some pretty pretty full-on stuff
yeah remember when you got to go to some
clinic somewhere and get your
vaccine ahead of the
crowd there yeah that didn't happen
wow talk about being a [ __ ]
listen
guess what that wears off you gotta go
get another one
like that's not a setup
billions are being made and that's why
they're turning away any other possible
solutions
there's like
that's there's no evidence of that i
mean billions are being made but there's
no evidence of the second part
see you got a bad cold right but you got
by the way it sounds like roseanne barr
but i know roseanne's politics aren't
like this
you got cough syrup you got your basic
at the drugstore right yeah you don't
have to go to the emergency for that
but they've taken away
something that someone could take
before they got in a position where they
needed to go to an emergency room
and yes
steroids are
a really bad drug
unless they're helping you not die
yeah so steroids haven't been taken away
i mean if it it's it's pretty typical
that for certain covado you give
dexamethasone or maybe they're using
prednisone
and we know about the effect of steroids
i mean it does it does suppress the
immune system to a degree but maybe
allows healing to take place there's
nothing new there's nothing
controversial there they're helping you
not die
goddamn how much do you how much is
pfizer paying you for this [ __ ]
you know what's funny about that
it's actually the anti-vaxx people that
are being paid
when the science is clear
you don't need to pay anyone to report
on the science and this is a very good
point that was made to me in the email
which is david you know when people
write to you and they say or they they
leave a voicemail saying you're getting
paid to promote the vaccine
first of all there's no evidence
anybody's being paid to promote the
vaccine
but you don't really need to pay people
to just look at science and report it
whereas we know of prominent
anti-vaxxers actually being paid
influencers really
how much are you you must be raking in
the bucks man to be going attacking
ivermectin
a human drug that's used worldwide for
years and it's on the world health
organization list of essential drugs for
humans well as we talked about before
used for roundworm uh parasites so this
this is uh this is just a peek into the
voicemail we've got a great bonus show
for you today
in the midst of all this texas
republican governor greg abbott is
banning all vaccine mandates
france will ban plastic packaging for
most fruits and vegetables that seems
logical right and we'll talk about
samsung's continued struggles with their
foldable mobile phones what's going on
there trouble
in tech paradise all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpacman.com and you will
get instant access
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 percent
off a subscription by going to
blinkist.com
david pakman